nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
le plan juppé le ministre de l'intérieur
totalisent environ six cent mille
manifestants
pour la cgt ils étaient 2 millions la
cgt qui annonce un nouveau temps fort
pour mardi alors que marc blondel pour
fo réclame l'ouverture immédiate du
sommet social
alain juppé ce soir maintient la date de
jeudi la sncf prévoit pour demain
dimanche la circulation d'un train sur
trois ou sur quatre lunes et jospin
demande au gouvernement des négociations
rapides pour éviter toute amertume pour
sommer journal également la fin du
sommet de madrid et les élections
législatives demain dimanche en russie
avec la victoire annoncée les
communistes
madame monsieur bonsoir malgré les
signes d'une reprise encore chaotique du
trafic sncf et ratp
la température sociale contre le plan
juppé reste élevé à l'appel notamment de
la cgt de force ouvrière et de la fsu
de très nombreux défilés ont été
organisés à paris en province
à paris le nombre des manifestants a été
évalué à plus de 300 milles par les
organisateurs et 56 milles selon la
préfecture de police
reportage agnès molinier et nos
différentes équipes
ils sont une nouvelle fois dans la rue
après 22 jours de conflit
aujourd'hui à paris plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de manifestants sont venus
soutenir la lutte des cheminots
je crois qu'elles montrent que les gens
qui veulent se battre sont capables de
gagner on l'a montré pendant 22 jours
voilà ça c'est un symbole manifeste un
petit peu de toi et puis on gagnera tous
les gens du privé qu'on est avec eux
aussi et on les remercie beaucoup de
nous avoir aidés
maintenant tout l'effort des
manifestants portent sur une seule chose
le retrait du plan de réforme de la
sécurité sociale présenté par le premier
ministre comme il a lié son plus haut
personnalité à son plan si on fait
tomber juppé ont fait tomber le plan on
veut leur talent pour les organisateurs
la cgt force ouvrière et les enseignants
de la fsu la mobilisation aujourd'hui
avec un but précis fusé sur les
négociations prévues à matignon jeudi
prochain le 21 décembre
le 21 c'est dans cinq jours encore une
fois on n'a pas l'impression que ça
trouble monsieur le premier ministre
qu'il y ait du monde dans la rue j'ai le
sentiment qu'il faudrait qu'ils écoutent
un petit peu et qu'ils sachent répondre
aux gens qu'ils l'attendent
nous appelons d'ailleurs à une nouvelle
journée mardi 19 qui prendra au niveau
des départements les formes de
manifestations assemblées générales
rassemblements bref mais qui apportera
la preuve que le mouvement social
restent mobilisés la journée
d'aujourd'hui a mobilisé bien et glas
des appareils syndicaux
malgré les appels à la reprise du
travail pour moi rêver à la c'est pas
parce qu'un tgv ou les quelques trains
de banlieue rôle que les cheminots
mais aujourd'hui dans les rues de paris
au delà des slogans et des
revendications
certains ont su garder la place au rêve
selon un communiqué du ministère de
l'intérieur les différentes
manifestations contre le plan juppé
aujourd'hui sur la réforme de la
protection sociale ont mobilisé au total
530 mille personnes dans 164 défilé hors
paris les chiffres de participation
donné de sources syndicales sont bien
évidemment supérieur la cgt parle de
quelques deux millions de manifestants à
paris et en province un rapide tour de
france en compagnie de patrice romain
l'avantagent du samedi c'est que cela
permet de manifester en famille à lille
quinze mille personnes prennent la rue
d'assaut les femmes les enfants d'abord
c'est pour leur avenir
c'est pour eux c'est pour leur retraite
pour un travail profond et l'agriculture
qui t'ont lenovo jean paul goude a fait
des émules direction nantes
ici les cheminots ont repris le travail
n'empêche dix mille personnes battent le
pavé
parmi elles des salariés du privé
on estime que pour le privé y a rien eu
de fait on a oublié qu'au privé en
impose 40 ans de cotisations direction
bordeaux maintenant ou sous une bannière
unitaire fo et la cgt en thelle quarante
mille personnes
à noter la présence de nombreuses
délégations cfdt
à noter également cette poignée de
médecins qu'il porte le deuil de la
médecine libérale
on est signe pour éviter que une
maîtrise médicalisée qui commençaient à
se mettre en place soit remplacé par une
maîtrise comptable qui à terme faux
débouchera obligatoirement sur un
rationnement des soins autre genre de
musique à toulouse
et oui vous l'avez reconnu claude
nougaro fait son numéro trente mille
personnes selon la préfecture 80 mille
selon les organisateurs parole nougaro
n'a jamais donné par et concert allait
il s'en doute ne sont pas venus pour lui
c'est plutôt lui qui est venu pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui avec le peuple
et des merlons
un chantier reprendrait marseille et
rester à la pointe du mouvement social
avec des transports en commun
pratiquement paralysé une gare toujours
vide et une manifestation qui a réuni
plusieurs dizaines demi de personnes
reportage yannick aroussi jean-françois
giorgetti toujours debout les cheminots
marseillais après plus de trois semaines
de grève
ils sont en tête de la manifestation
comme ils l'ont été depuis le début du
mouvement social
alors même si la tendance est à la
reprise ils ont voté la poursuite de la
grève aujourd'hui et nos grandes
victoires pour les cheminots le
mouvement continue peut-être sous
d'autres formes et sur carré les autres
salariés
la détermination c'est le moule warfare
impayés le plan juppé pour jean paul
liot conducteurs de train c'est la
septième manifestation dans les rues de
marseille
il est bien sûr satisfait des
concessions obtenues par les cheminots
mais il regrette que les salariés du
privé ne soit pas plus présent si les
gens du privé étaient entrés dans le
mouvement
ça n'aurait pas duré trois semaines ça
aurait duré à peine une semaine c'est
toute la différence
nestlé pechiney entreprises du btp
quelques salariés du secteur privé des
films comme ses employés de la fnac
compte débrayé pour manifester ça veut
vraiment dire qu'on est solidaire et
qu'on ait des citoyens
on est des citoyens un peu bruit mais
dans les entreprises
imbali années et que bon on vient
d'exprimer aussi elle qu'on est vraiment
contre ce plan
un compte mille manifestants selon la
police 5000 selon les syndicats des
représentants de tous les secteurs de la
fonction publique la mobilisation contre
le plan juppé faibli ta peine à
marseille pas de bus aujourd'hui une
circulation ferroviaire toujours nul les
assemblées générales de cheminots
détermineront la suite du mouvement
exceptionnellement les poids lourds ont
été autorisés à circuler ce week-end sur
tout le territoire
la reprise du trafic ferroviaire
s'effectue en effet extrêmement
lentement et plusieurs régions sont
toujours totalement bloqué un peu plus
d'un établissement sncf sur deux avait
voté ce matin la reprise du travail
reportage à lyon benoît gallerey olivier
jacquin
la vie du rail reprend gare de lyon sur
les quais les usagers on retrouve le
sourire étonné très étonné pourquoi
enfin parce que je pensais pas je
téléphone il ya une heure et à
renseignements m'a dit qu'il y avait un
train première bonne surprise pour les
voyageurs du tgv la réservation gratuite
et le tarif le plus bas systématiquement
appliquée pendant quelques jours alors
sncf c'est pas si mal que ça on ne leur
en veux pas mais encore on trouve quand
même que ça faisait maintenant un peu
long un peu long également pour le
matériel quelques portes refusé de
s'ouvrir ce matin d'où un léger retard
au départ de lyon bien toléré par les
clients
j'avais réservé un trail en billets
d'avion que nous a dit qu'elle était
aussi la grève des aiguilleurs du ciel
c'est assez catastrophique je suis
vraiment content vraiment entre paris et
lyon huit tgv circuleront demain dans
les deux sens le trafic reprend peu à
peu en direction des alpes en revanche
les régions de marseille et montpellier
reste inaccessible pour cette reprise
progressive de l'activité
la sncf se donne des priorités premières
priorités pour une fois c'est le fret
nous voulons aider la plupart des
entreprises qui ont souffert et je ne le
regrettons de 7,2 ce mouvement très
longs et donc nous souhaitons les aider
pour remettre au maximum leurs
installations en service
autre priorité les trains régionaux et
les départs en vacances à lyon
le retour à la normale est prévu pour
mercredi
la sncf qui a mis en place un numéro
vert le 0 5 15 24 24 afin de permettre
aux usagers de s'informer très
précisément notamment en ce qui concerne
l'île de france
a la ratp là aussi un numéro vert forte
utile le 05 15 11 11
la situation est en effet plutôt confuse
en fin d'après-midi cinq lignes de métro
sur 13 et la ligne a du rer fonctionner
partiellement sur la suite de ce
mouvement les français semblent
extrêmement partagées si l'on en croit
un sondage ifop publié par le monde
36% des français estiment que les grèves
sont normales et doivent continuer tant
que les grévistes n'auront pas obtenu
satisfaction
34% des français estiment que ces grèves
sont normales mais qu'elles ont
aujourd'hui trop duré je vous disais en
titre dans une lettre adressée aux
leaders syndicaux alain juppé maintien à
jeudi prochain la date du sommet social
à matignon
10il arlette chabot il va falloir gérer
la sortie
oui la tendance est effectivement à la
reprise notamment à la sncf même si la
mobilisation reste forte on l'a vu
aujourd'hui dans les rues on le constate
vous l'avais dit à la ratp
alors les organisations syndicales qui
ont su garder le contact avec la base ce
qui a évité les coordinations doivent
maintenant accompagner la sortie de
crise elles ont obtenu la mise entre
parenthèses des régimes spéciaux le
retrait du contrat de plan à la sncf et
celle n'ont pas réussi à élargir le
mouvement au secteur privé elles ont
bénéficié d'une compréhension de
l'opinion publique qui a fait un peu
grève par procuration
le gouvernement lui s'il a reculé peut
se satisfaire ce soir d'avoir maintenu
l'essentiel de la réforme de la sécurité
sociale notamment la maîtrise des
dépenses de santé a lui aussi maintenant
d'accompagner la sortie de crise en
ouvrant vraiment le dialogue jeudi
prochain lors de ce fameux sommet social
réclamée par les syndicats mais reste je
dirais l'essentiel le malaise révélé par
ses conflits le ras-le-bol des français
auxquels on demande des sacrifices
depuis 20 ans au nom de la crise le
malaise des classes peuvent moyenne
petit fonctionnaire ou salarié du
secteur privé qui ne se sentent pas des
privilégiés parce qu'ils gagnent dix
mille ou douze mille francs par mois
la peur de tous face au delà de l'europe
à la mondialisation de l'économie et
l'absence de perspectives bref la peur
de l'avenir
pire pour les parents et leurs enfants
c'est aussi la fracture sociale qui
s'est rappelé au bon souvenir du
gouvernement et les responsables
politiques en général
alors s'il n'apporte pas de réponse
adaptée s'il ne pratique pas le dialogue
qui consiste à parler mais aussi à
écouter
il y aura sans doute d'autres secousses
comme celle que nous traversons
aujourd'hui
merci conséquence entre autres des
grèves mais surtout de la morosité
ambiante
une majorité de français pensent
dépenser moins pour les fêtes que l'an
dernier selon un sondage louis harris
ceux publiés demain par l'hebdomadaire
votre dimanche
en ile-de-france le commerce on l'a dit
a beaucoup souffert des grèves dans les
transports publics
on a noté aujourd'hui un net
frémissement positif mais pas réellement
la grande affluence attendue
reportage mary pierce hamiti stéphane
chopin on a flâné aujourd'hui sur les
trottoirs de la rue de vienne à paris on
a flâné sans se bousculer loin d'ici la
grande cohue espéré par les commerçants
le nombre les clients et de surcroît
d'une mauvaise humeur même pas de taxis
ont cette fois que son père le grand
marchandage
ça nous arrange pas de me prend pour un
vin dans le plus populaire des magasins
de la rue on a senti un léger
frémissement
c'est vrai tout de même on attend les
clients et on mise beaucoup sur les
prochains jours l espoir fait vivre
commandé 60 concerts notre cher
peut-être que francoeur devra redresser
la barre tout est possible la société
affiche 30 à 50 fonctions de ventes en
moins si l'on les magasins on vient
quand on peut ainsi y a pas de métro et
à pied là ça vous a empêché d'acheter
beaucoup de la chose et oui parce que
j'aurais voulu avoir aller à barbès est
beaucoup plus grand et je peux pas être
plus rien
la feria puisqu'on peut d'abord que les
enfants ont déjoué c'est leur joie les
grands magasins du boulevard haussmann
ont connu une affluence en hausse de 10
% aujourd'hui
rien d'extraordinaire d'ailleurs le
rayon des jouets étaient plutôt calmes
ce sont les premières courses on peut
venir avec les enfants parce qu'on a pu
prendre un rer tout à l'heure
heureusement et donc on arrive ici on
compte 25 % de clients en moins par
rapport à l'an dernier
le chiffre d'affaires est en baisse de
50%
on fait un peu pâle eu moins de la
moitié du chili année dernière est ce
que vous pensez rattraper d'ici la
semaine prochaine
écoutez si les transports se rétablisse
nous en attrapant une partie mais bien
évidemment nous serons incapables de
rattraper la totalité du retard que nous
avons malheureusement engrangé et dans
les grandes maisons de haute couture la
tendance était aussi à la morosité
d'ailleurs cette morosité qui dure a
donné quelques idées pour faire rêver
des clients un peu trop mélancolique
cet après midi à paris il y avait ceux
et celles qui marchait dans les défilés
syndicaux et les autres qui eux aussi
est elle aussi bon mais notre bon gré
mal gré fortifier leurs mots les croquis
signé maurice richard
vassallo
et
ce sens plus rien chez moi c'est au tour
de france aucun problème à me relever
l'autre matin
ses partenaires vraiment vécu
quelles sont celles du parti socialiste
n'ont pas fait de sport aujourd'hui le
pse réuni en convention nationale s'est
déclaré solidaire du mouvement social
pour michel rocard il ne faut pas
abandonné l'objectif de réformer
l'assurance maladie
mais cela dit il ne doit pas se faire à
la trique pour lionel jospin il faut que
le gouvernement négocie rapidement pour
aboutir à une solution qui ne laisse à
personne un goût amer reportage
guilaine chenu patrick des suisses se
pencher sur un mouvement social partant
de grève
cela donne d'abord des feuilles de
présence à moitié vide cela donne
ensuite chez les socialistes des débats
infinis sur le rôle de nos positions
dans ce conflit la place dans
socialistes est d'être dans les défilés
et dans le mouvement autant qu'il peut
l'être moi je me suis pas roulant sncf
mais en tant que parlementaires
socialistes ou élus ou militants
tout le monde doit y être le problème
c'est plutôt est ce que le parti
socialiste a été solidaire ou pas
solidaires du mouvement social il l'a
été c'est une très bonne chose pour moi
depuis le début du mouvement les nail
j'espère n'a pas varié sur la forme
soutien aux grévistes et refuse de
politiser le conflit sur le fond non
plonge ip mais oui à la réforme
une position mesurée trop prudentes pour
la gauche minoritaire du pf
mais une position juste pour la majorité
des cadres tous derrière leur premier
secrétaire je crois qu'il est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement de faire
en sorte que ce gouvernement que ce
mouvement le moment venu se termine
justement d'une façon qui soit ressenti
comme positive
au ps on ne peut pas encore tirer de
conclusion de ce conflit on pense
maintenant à se refaire une santé et
retrouver des électeurs sortir de la
convalescence aussi en proposant une
alternative ont beaucoup de temps parce
qu'à mon avis il y avait eu l'habitude
de travailler avait été un petit peu
perdues qu'il faut reprendre à zéro un
certain nombre de questions mais
justement là c'est une course de vitesse
il faut maintenant accélérer les débats
le mois de mars est la date que s'est
fixé lionel jospin pour proposer un
début de projet de gauche
avant tout je veux garder son rythme
prendre ce temps et respecter le
calendrier électoral
selon un sondage ifop publié demain par
le jdd pour la première fois depuis plus
de six mois
les cotes de popularité de jacques
chirac et d'alain juppé ont connu un
frémissement à la hausse en décembre
avec 30% de satisfaits pour le président
contre 27 pour cent le mois dernier et
28% de satisfaits pour le premier
ministre qui enregistre cependant un
chiffre record de mécontents 67%
les quinze chefs d'état et de
gouvernement réunis à madrid en sommet
ce week-end ont réalisé une percée
significative sur la monnaie européenne
et ils ont lancé un signal positif pour
l'ouverture dans deux ans de
négociations mais qu'une dizaine de pays
ex communiste candidat à l'adhésion à
l'union européenne à madrid pour france
2 christophe marie mono jan cornet
madrid aura apporté sa pierre la maison
europe comprise en euros n'ont pas et qu
la monnaie unique avec un calendrier
précis 1er janvier 99 pour l'application
2002 pour le porte-monnaie du citoyen à
compter de cette date
finie la monnaie nationale place à
l'euro en souhaitant également
l'élargissement de leur offre aux
candidats à l'adhésion et 15 sont prêts
à accueillir à leur table des pays
pour ces variés que la pologne la
roumanie chypre malte
quant à l'europe sociale pas de
nouvelles initiatives
cela constat le chômage et l'échec de
l'europe a souligné le chancelier helmut
kohl
le président français n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer sur les conflits sociaux en
france
il s'est déclaré convaincu que venait
unique et emploie ferait bon ménage
nous devons avoir aujourd'hui un pôle
monétaire européen fort si nous voulons
limiter les dégâts que cause sur nos
économies les fluctuations adhérentes du
dollar nous devons en terminer avec les
dévaluations compétitives en europe et
qui nous ont fait tant mal
donc il y a à l'évidence une synergie
entre stabilité des taux de change et
développement dont croissance donc
l'emploi derrière l'unanimité de façade
quelques tensions sérieuses et
britanniques sont furieux contre la
monnaie unique appelée euros est les
italiens franchement hostile aux essais
nucléaires français
la présidence italienne qui débute en
janvier prochain promet d'être beaucoup
plus agitée que la présidence espagnole
élections légistatives demain en russie
6 mois avant un scrutin présidentiel
tout à fait décisif
la russie qui va peut être tourner
demain une page de son histoire les
candidats communistes sont en effet
donnés favoris parmi les supporteurs du
pc beaucoup de personnes âgées mais
aussi de nombreux déçus de la réforme
économique reportage de dominique derda
et de georges en scène dans une usine de
fabrication de tracteurs présenté en son
temps comme une vitrine des
privatisations
longtemps ils furent les héros du régime
communiste
puis gilles courteau réforme la
démocratie pour eux signifiait avant
tout un bon salaire une voiture neuve un
frigo plein 7 est en 1991
l'union soviétique launay de s'effondrer
grâce à boris eltsine et à tous ses
conseillers libéraux usine de tracteurs
de vladimir la plus grande de russie
devait être la vitrine des
privatisations réussi mais la production
est en chute libre
cinq fois moins qu'il ya dix ans on
parle de 2000 nouveaux licenciements
avant la fin de l'année déjà les dix
mille employés ne travaillent plus que
deux ou trois jours par semaine ont
pensé que tout irait mieux
nous sommes devenus une société par
actions on a eu un nouveau directeur
nous on le voit aucune amélioration
salaire moyen 200 francs par mois
et encore celui de novembre ils
attendent toujours avec ça à peine de
quoi se loger se nourrir
rien d'autre avant quand on partait en
vacances au temps de l'union soviétique
on avait suffisamment d'argent pour
aller jusqu'à l'au delà du pays jusqu'en
extrême orient maintenant je suis
sincère francs de créances
mais pour aller jusque là le billet
coûte 2 3 ou 4000 francs l'espoir d'une
vie meilleure c'est bien vite envolés
alors même les jeunes ouvrières se
tourner vers le parti communiste qui
leur promet de rendre le pouvoir au
peuple
moi c'est les communistes que je préfère
leur programme riche pour les ouvriers
parce qu'ils sont au dessus de ceux qui
sont là ils n'ont pas intérêt à ce que
les communistes eux gagnent mais ce qui
va se passer après on n'en sait rien aux
élections municipales de mars dernier
les habitants de vladimir ont réinstallé
une majorité de conseillers communistes
et vladimir n'est pas une exception pour
les mêmes raisons parce que ce sont
toujours les petits qui supportent le
coût des réformes elles sont nombreuses
ces villes ou aux législatives de demain
les fidèles de lénine sont donnés
favoris en france les élections
professionnelles chez les 92 mille
policiers en tenue ont marqué une forte
progression de 2 syndicat proche de
l'extrême droite qui ont totalisé près
de 13% des voix reportage michel fils
roger matures
à l'origine ce devait être une réunion
de gardiens de la paix pour fêter les
résultats des élections dans la police
la soirée électorale du sgp principales
composantes de la fédération autonome
des syndicats de police la phase
majoritaire est classé à gauche
et puis au fil des résultats les
sourires se sont figés l'extrême droite
venait de rafler 13% des voix grâce à la
création d'un nouveau syndicat front
national de la police bien fota qui
accusent le gouvernement actuel et notre
ministre de l'intérieur partisane assuré
pendant tout de suite devant table les
syndicats majoritaires de faire le jeu
de rester droit et du fascisme par la
police nos collègues sont excusables par
là parce que notre collègue alain tassé
depuis des mois des années démission des
pouvoirs publics crise des syndicats
font national de la police ne répond pas
et profite de sa victoire en silence au
siège de la fuite qui représentait salle
jusqu'ici l'extrême droite dans la
police ont fait ce simple constat
l'émergence d'un nouveau syndicat a fait
perdre des voix il ya beaucoup
d'insatisfaits la banlieue de plus en
plus difficile le travail devient plus
en plus difficile et problèmes
d'effectif partout donc automatiquement
on se verse
on a une ex maison pour le front
national pour tout ce qui est extrême et
qui va qui va forcément faire bouger les
choses
le grand perdant de ces élections c'est
finalement la fasp et son nouveau patron
jacques il y aller la fédération
autonome n'est plus majoritaire elle est
passée de 50 à 42 % des voix c'est un
coup dur pour le syndicalisme de gauche
dans la politique à une semaine des
vacances scolaires appuyé par des
stations de sports d'hiver ont ouvert
leurs pistes pour pallier l'absence de
trains certaines stations savoyardes ont
affrété directement des cars au départ
de paris valérie astruc et alain poirier
ont fait le voyage de nuit jusqu'à val
d'isère avec quelques-uns de ces
irréductibles de la poudreuse se serait
cru à paris bien avant les grèves ils
sont pressés ses skieurs et pour cause
c'est leur premier jour de ski à val
d'isère la capitale il l'en qui paie il
y a à peine douze heures
ce sont les irréductibles de la montagne
pas de voiture pas [ __ ]
plus qu'une solution le quart de nuit au
départ de paris je sais même pas les bus
couchettes ou payer combien mille francs
où il fera l'aller retour
on devrait faire
les jambes fléchies font faux bond à la
guerre comme à la guerre
22h les cars affrétés par les stations
savoyardes qui femmes après qu'elles
plus inévitable embouteillages
l'attention battre le sou ralentit déjà
les bienfaits de la montagne se font
saintignon 8 heures du matin ils foulent
le sol de val d'isère soulagement on est
content d'être arrivé on peut en
profiter apparemment il ya de la neige
s'amuser soulagement aussi des
commerçants de la station qui ont déjà
perdu beaucoup de clients
elle ya une double perte ya une perte
défection de la part de la clientèle
d'une part et d'autre part des
réservations et des arts qui n'arrive
plus mais ses débuts difficiles pour la
station sont liées aussi à la météo via
l'engagement il est pas ce qu'ils
devraient être à cette époque parce que
leur époque là il y avait beaucoup de
neige
bref plus manque de neige résultats 30%
de skieurs en moins que l'année dernière
à la même époque mais val d'isère n'est
pas inquiet les réservations pour les
vacances de noël s'annonce une image
étonnante maintenant qui nous vient d'un
parc naturel de l'orégon états unis où
un chat et un grizzly sont devenus les
meilleurs amis du monde
l'oursin grisy de 250 kg vivait seule
dans son enclos lorsqu'il a vu arriver
il ya quelques mois un chaton affamés le
petit félin n'a pas servi de déjeuner au
plantigrade bien deux compères et depuis
vous voyez 4 et grises vivent dans la
meilleure harmonie possible est
maintenant l'heure de notre petite
devinette qui a créé la première crèche
réponse saint françois d'assise en 12
123 depuis la capitale mondiale de la
crèche et naples n'en déplaise aux
provençaux les napolitains qui en ont
fait un véritable business
reportage alain chatriot naples est
connue comme la capitale mondiale des
pâtes et de la pizza
mais saviez vous qu'elle est aussi la
capitale des crèches tout un quartier de
la ville leur est ainsi dédié sommet
goriot arméno dans les ruelles de ce
quartier
ce ne sont que des boutiques et des
fabricants de crèches de santons
d'accessoires des dizaines et des
dizaines de gouttes on en trouve pour
tous les goûts avec sans moteur et même
pour les musulmans avec cette crèche
mosquée on y trouve toutes sortes de
cent ponts plus ou moins bon marché de
plus ou moins bon goût
on y trouve aussi des oeuvres d'art il
faut compter entre 15 et 20 millions de
lires 50 à 60 enfants et de ne pas
essentielle anciennes se servaient des
centaines de millions dans les
arrière-boutiques vos premiers étages
ce sont les ateliers on le fabrique les
personnages en terre glaise
on n'est pas à la main après cuisson on
les habille soigneusement et on assemble
le tout je fais ce métier depuis je suis
tout petit et déjà mes parents le
faisait cela fait deux trois générations
mais le plus connu de tous ces artisans
est sans conteste josep et ferrigno
cinquième d'une lignée qui remonte au
siècle dernier
la crèche napolitaine
j'ai une scène de la vie parce qu'il ya
des métiers qui à l'époque n'existait
pas il y a des poissonniers leur priseur
de chaussettes
le vendeur de légumes le charcutier le
boucher tous les personnages une petite
ville reconstruit c'est vrai qu'avec
tous ces ingrédients on est bien loin de
bethléem mais à nabeul
on n'a jamais gp un paradoxe près
je vous propose de terminer ce journal
dans la grâce avec une démonstration de
danse e bhutto cela en compagnie de la
troupe japonaise sankai juku qui se
produit au théâtre de la ville à paris
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
reportage bruno albin filles montrent
aussi en ces temps où l'on court après
le temps des danseurs en quête d'un
univers de sérénité
depuis 20 ans sankai juku porte à
travers le monde le bouton la danse des
ténèbres surgi du désespoir d'hiroshima
à l'époque où le japon anéanti se jeter
dans les bras de ses vainqueurs des
artistes retourner aux racines de leur
culture
aujourd'hui c'est la seconde génération
du butoh mais l'héritage transparaît
toujours
e
le butoh politique laisse le public en
liberté tout au long du spectacle
célébration d'un art qui curieusement ne
se définit pas j'imagine que je ne
saurai jamais le définir j'avais donc
continuer le voyage de la danse c'est ce
voyage et cette quête qui sont l'oeuvre
elle même
non
la danse ne s'interrompt pas ce sont les
lumières qui s'éteignent laissant chacun
prolonger d'émotion presque un
envoûtement
et puisque nous sommes au pays des
merveilles j'en profite pour souhaiter
une bonne fête aux alice dernier journal
un peu après minuit en compagnie de
florence dauchez demain à midi sur
france 2 bien sûr des missions polémique
de michèle cotta reviendra bien
évidemment sur les mouvements sociaux
avec entre autres invités le porte
parole du gouvernement alain lamassoure
celui du ps dominique strauss kahn et le
président du cnpf jean gandois dans un
instant la météo laurent romejko avec
toujours des risques de verglas demain
matin à demain 13h excellente soirée
merci